well joining me now is retired Air Vice
Marshall Sean Bell and Sean why do the
ukrainians think that the Russian
offensive to come will be more intense
well it's a great question because the
challenge is has the Russian military
actually been spent and this is more a
request for Ukraine for more weapons uh
or or are they genuinely a really
credible threat for this forthcoming
spring offensive part of the answer is
that lies I think if we look back in
history Russia when it initially
launched The Invasion on the 24th of
February it uh expected just to walk
into the country that didn't work
expensive then to go and attack Kiev and
try and take that that didn't work and
Russia's found itself locked now its
third attack into the donbass in a
grinding War of Attrition which is a war
that actually was not prepared for and
it stalled at that point then the Wagner
group was brought in to try to make some
progress around back moots and around
the southern area here despite massive
casualties they didn't make much
progress but what it did do was bought
time for the Russians they've mobilized
320 000 of their new recruits half of
them have been deployed half of them are
just finishing their training at the
moment and it's worth remembering that
Russian domestic frustration they've
seen Rising casualty is a lack of
progress so President Putin is very well
motivated to get a claim a decisive
Victory and soon
and in terms of what we might expect
from the Russian military what do you
think
the Russians have taken a beating over
the last year but actually they are our
major power and we fully expect them to
to learn from their mistakes they now
know what the threats that the Ukraine
poses they know what capabilities work
and they also most importantly know what
doesn't work which means that for the
spring Russia will be better prepared
and therefore will be more dangerous the
challenge is they've still got the same
weapons to use and although they've
created quantity with their soldiers
they're not quality and they're not
experienced so part of the challenge is
if they were able to mount an all-arms
approach by that I mean if the soldiers
can operate effectively with the tanks
and the artillery and the Russian Air
Force then they would pose a really
major threat on the battlefield the
challenge is though Western analysts
believe that they will just continue
doing the same thing they've been doing
throwing mass at the ukrainians and of
course that makes them vulnerable to
Western weapons
um it'll be but regardless we expect the
Russian offensive to be absolutely big
focused dangerous but also with a clear
set of objectives where almost certainly
the North of the Dom bass up the top
there but the main focus will almost
certainly about around back moot the
real question though is what they do
about zaparita and these they'll want to
respond to the potential Ukraine threat
down there the dangers if they split
Russia spits their resources too far the
danger is neither work and that could
end up with a bit of a route
you talk about Russia being better
prepared but of course so will the
ukrainians they certainly will have more
tanks won't they they will and I think
that's part of what we expect to see
from the ukrainians is that these tanks
are going to take time to arrive and
therefore almost certainly because these
tanks will be decisive they'll not want
to get locked into a nutritional battle
before they arrive as a result we fully
expect that sort of phase one of their
spring campaign for the ukrainians will
almost certainly be a defensive play
rely on Western support for weapons and
make the Russian offensive uh be huge
casualty rates inflict huge casualties
on the Russians and when the Russian
military culminate that will be the time
when they will be able to push them back
where we expect that to happen it could
happen in the donbass area for the
Ukrainian push but to be honest be
really difficult to make significant
ground there what's most likely is that
they need to sever this land bridge down
here to the east of zaparita using their
tanks major punch down to the coast here
because what that would do there's a lot
of Russian positions all the way along
this donipro River here that are
pounding away at Harrison as soon as
they've cut the land bridge here that
would mean that most the Russians would
have to flee and almost certainly rushed
to Crimea the reality is this though is
we genuinely don't know clear that's in
the minds of the military there'll be
deception plans information operations
but it's pretty clear we're set for some
decisive months of battle ahead